vamos a dibujar un triángulo aquí voy a
poner un lado con otro color voy a poner
el otro de los lados y finalmente voy a
poner un tercer lado por acá y vamos a
pensar que el lado azul mide 6 que el
lado rosa mide 10 y que el lado verde
mide x entonces una buena pregunta es
ver cuánto es lo mínimo y lo máximo que
puede valer x sabiendo que los otros
lados son 6 y 10 vamos a empezar
pensando cuánto es lo mínimo que puede
valer x y para eso queremos acercar este
punto a este punto de acá con lo cual
tenemos que hacer este ángulo lo más
pequeño posible entonces déjame hacer
que ese ángulo sea más o menos pequeño
vamos a poner aquí el lado de longitud
10 entonces lo que tendríamos que hacer
es que este lado de longitud 6 quedara
con un ángulo muy pequeño es más déjame
hacerlo más pequeño como por acá vale 6
entonces si tenemos que este ángulo es
muy pequeño este punto va a estar muy
cerca de este punto y entonces x va a
ser muy pequeño pero que es tan pequeño
puede ser bueno qué sucede si este
ángulo sigue haciéndose más y más y más
pequeño que sucede cuando este ángulo
llega a
pero digamos en este caso tendríamos un
triángulo degenerado no sería un
triángulo de adeveras porque pues todos
sus lados estarían en una misma línea
aquí está aquí estaría al lado de
longitud 10 por aquí estaría al lado de
longitud 6 sería algo como de este
estilo estaría ahí encima do en este
mismo lado sería 6 y aquí tendríamos el
lado de longitud x
esto de aquí es el lado de longitud x y
claramente esto es lo más cercano que
pueden estar estos dos puntos bueno si
aquí esto mide 6 y todo mide 10 en este
caso x mediría 4 estoy aquí mediría 4 y
tendríamos que el menor valor que puede
tomar x es 4 pero nosotros no queremos
triángulos degenerados porque esos
triángulos como que están muy flacos y
en realidad pues no están en dos
dimensiones así que lo que tenemos que
pedir para que sea de veras sea un
triángulo es que x sea mayor que 4
entonces x puede ser tan cercano a 4
como queramos pero tiene que ser mayor
estrictamente vale ahora vamos a ver qué
tan grande puede ser x si queremos que
aquí sea grande ahora este ángulo debe
ser grande debe ser cercano a 180 grados
en este caso tendríamos algo de este
estilo
conforme conforme el ángulo se va
haciendo muy grande déjame ponerle un
poco más chiquito o algo como así
conforme el ángulo se va haciendo más
grande entonces aquí tenemos algo muy
cercano a 180 grados aquí sería 10 aquí
sería 6
déjame ponerlo a exiliar 6 aquí sería 10
entonces esto es este punto de acá y
este punto de acá estarían muy alejados
y esta longitud que es equis pues sería
muy grande verdad pero qué tan grande
puede ser qué tan grande puede ser bueno
pues otra vez nos vamos al caso extremo
vamos a pensar que este ángulo realmente
se hace de 180 grados entonces ahí
tendríamos un segmento de longitud 10
por acá un segmento de longitud 6 por
acá 6 bueno déjame hacerlo un poco más
derechito como así tiene que quedar
alineado vale entonces aquí sería 6 aquí
sería 10 y en este caso x me diría la
distancia entre este punto y este punto
o sea que aquí x sería igual sería igual
a 16 pero una vez más este caso que es
el caso extremo forma un triángulo
degenerado sus vértices están alineados
entonces no es un triángulo de adeveras
de forma que lo máximo que puede valer x
para así tener un triángulo es pues algo
menos que 16 entonces x sería menor
menor
estricto a 16 entonces x mínimo es 4 y
máximo es 16 pero estas ideas en
realidad pues vienen de un concepto más
general que se llama el teorema de la
desigualdad del triángulo y lo que dice
este teorema es simplemente que si
tenemos un lado en un triángulo entonces
ese es menor que la suma de los otros
dos lados lo voy a poner aquí la
longitud la longitud de un lado
de un triángulo es menor estricto que la
suma suma de las otras dos longitudes
otras dos dos longitudes muy bien y
bueno o sea si queremos contemplar a los
ángulos a los triángulos que son
triángulos aquí degenerados que están
flaquitos aquí le podríamos poner un
menor o igual pero déjame quitárselo
vale para que sean triángulos de
adeveras entonces en este caso la
longitud de un lado es menor que la suma
de las otras dos longitudes y eso es
exactamente lo que está sucediendo aquí
observa que pues de este lado podemos
decir que x es menor que la suma de los
otros dos lados que 6 más 10
+ + 10 y eso es pues exactamente que x
es menor de 16 menor que 16 lo mismo que
obtuvimos con el análisis del caso
extremo vale y de este otro lado podemos
también aplicar la desigualdad del
triángulo pero para el lado 10 entonces
que nos diría nos diría que 1010 es
menor que x + 6 que x más 6 más 6 y
restando 6 de ambos lados obtenemos que
que 4 es menor que x o bien que x es
mayor que 4 y eso fue exactamente lo
mismo que obtuvimos con el análisis de
caso extremo vale bueno entonces pues
este teorema de la desigualdad del
triángulo parece ser una idea muy básica
pero te vas a enfrentar con él en muchos
problemas avanzados pueden ser problemas
complicados de geometría o de vectores
pero en el fondo está esta idea sencilla
de que la suma de dos lados de un
triángulo siempre le ganan al tercero